desperate times call for desperate
measures and
times are really desperate right now for
fox news channel
now you might be wondering why what's
going on why are things so desperate for
fox
fox news attached their wagon so to
speak to the wrong horse
that horse being donald trump and donald
trump lost the election
badly and then humiliated himself
and the american right by waging the
wacky
baseless fight to try to steal the
election from the rightful winner joe
biden
that we all observed together for a
period of several months
and this had a number of different uh
repercussions it led to many republicans
abandoning the republican party
but it also led to lots of fox news
viewers
leaving fox news for oan and newsmax
which more
reliably welcomed and pushed and
entertained any and every hairbrained
conspiracy theory
about the election so fox news's ad
dollars
are collapsing ratings for some of their
key
shows are way down from before the
election including the sean hannity
program
and fox news is in a panic what do they
do what do we do
they have been asking so they are going
back to the strategy
that got them to where they are in the
first place
manufactured scandals about democratic
politicians
think benghazi think obama's tan suit
think the war on christmas migrant
caravans at convenient times
that type of thing and the new one on
tucker carlson's show
this is just something else the new one
that
tucker has concocted with his producers
is that the relationship between joe and
jill biden
that appears to be a loving relationship
a seeming return to a couple that likes
each other
which is a big change from donald and
melania trump's
relationship the claim is that jill and
joe biden's relationship
is actually a fake stage managed public
relations campaign
take a look at this at the heart of this
great american family is a love story
one man one woman in the fires of
passion that changed the course of our
history
not since anthony died with cleopatra in
downtown antioch before they killed
themselves obviously
has a country witnessed a love story as
moving and poignant as jill and joe's
no ladies and gentlemen jill biden is
not joe's caretaker she isn't his nurse
she's his fully equal romantic partner
together they are like besotted teens
yet at the same
time they are the wise and knowing
parents of a nation
as a headline from politico on
valentine's day put it quote
historians and relationship experts
agree
the first couple's romantic gestures
aren't just genuine
they're restorative so it's official the
biden's affection is totally real it's
in no way part of a slick pr campaign
devised by cynical consultants
determined to hide the president's
senility by misdirection
not at all their love is as real as
climate change
so i have a few thoughts on this this is
an example
of the performative outrage that we
talked about last week among the right
of finding things to be outraged about
that
are just ridiculous and secondly
understand that
this doesn't get on tv on a whim i
i don't know exactly how many minutes of
commercials there are during tucker
carlson's show but if it's
similar to many other cable news shows
you know it's somewhere between
18 and 23 minutes of commercials that
leaves about 37 or so minutes of content
every single one of those 37 minutes is
very highly produced
meaning that this story was pitched
at some kind of morning meeting uh and
as a group they decided
yes let's go with this story let's go
with this story about
joe and jill biden's relationship being
some kind of
fake act and then of course being tucker
he has to throw in their relationship is
as real as climate change which is part
of how
they are packing up packaging up their
response to the texas power outages
which we talked about earlier in the
show
to blame wind power and claim that
climate change is fake but understand
the other part of why they're actually
doing this
they are panicking because not only is
their guy out of power
and not only have their guys followers
increasingly
opted for newsmax and oan because
fox coverage apparently isn't crazy
enough people
also like what joe biden is doing and
this has fox news in an absolute tizzy
joe biden has the highest initial
approval rating of any president in 28
years
fox news is panicking because of that
joe biden has 69
approval on his handling of covet under
joe biden
average daily vaccinations have gone
from 890
000 on trump's last day in office to 1.7
million vaccinations a day and
continuing to climb that's uh that's
basically doubling
in 26 days in office and they continue
to accelerate
joe biden is apparently eventually
going to get covered relief done without
republicans and the country wants
coveted relief
but fox news just continues to interview
republicans who are against it
so fox news has to manufacture
something and this is what they've
chosen to go with now
is this going to work to pull audience
back from oan and newsmax i have no idea
it's hard for me to put myself in the
mindset of what
someone who used to watch fox news but
was lured away
by newsmax and oan like what exactly do
they want what are they looking for i
don't know
it's hard for me to imagine what would
bring them back since to me it's crazy
to have been lured away
in the first place but this appears to
be the way
that many fox news programs are going
and we predicted they would go back to
the same stuff
the equivalent of the obama wore a tan
suit and like the wrong mustard
type of thing uh the manufactured
scandals the fake
or performative outrage they're doing
the debt and deficit
small government uh the war on christmas
and religious freedom all of these
different things that
they abandoned for the most part during
donald trump's presidency so we'll see
what fox news
fox news looks like in two months we're
already starting to get a sense of the
playbook they're going back to
in the um uh aftermath
of the trump presidency and then the
next question will be
if fox does a what is it
that newsmax and oan will do i don't
know the answer but it's going to be
some wild times